and his crew were supposed to already be
at sea
but they've been having problems
first it was the motor and then the
transmission
but mechanical failures can't deter
hypno from his humanitarian mission
he and his crew are working on a project
called sea watch that aims to find
refugees stranded at sea and force
european authorities to help them
hupna and three other families pulled
their money to buy this nearly 100 year
old boat
hypna is outraged by images of people
desperate to reach europe fleeing
poverty and persecution and risking
their lives in hopelessly overcrowded
rubber dinghies
he says the mediterranean sea is
europe's border
and since germany is part of europe that
creates a responsibility
if you acknowledge that several thousand
people are going to die on germany's
external border this year
then i have to do something that
motivation comes from within i can't
accept an injustice like this
the sea watch is a former fishing vessel
a lot of work still needs to be done to
adapt it to its new purpose
here he tries to get his head around a
bewildering tangle of wires
ironically the 41 year old hepner is a
landlubber
so he's enlisted veteran sailors like
captain tillman holston as volunteers
for the project
in the mediterranean the boat might sail
around for weeks without seeing anything
but we may sail by the bodies of dead
children then the crew might be so
traumatized that they'll have to put
into port we simply don't know
back in the machine room the mechanical
problems have been solved
the sea watch is ready to set out on a
short test trip
if all goes well the vessel will soon
patrol the mediterranean looking to help
those in desperate need